Nir, how are you?
Good. How are you, Michael?
Fantastic!
Thank you so much for joining
me on 20 Minute Leaders.
It’s already nighttime ,
obviously, in Israel,
so even more thank you
for taking the time to join me.
No worries.
Standard working hours.
Standard working hours for
a CEO of an early stage start-up.
That has to, obviously,
do both US and Israel.
So wonderful.
You know, Nir,
so much experience
in the machine learning  and
artificial  intelligence space,
research and from Google,
and most recently,
the company that
you founded, Allegro.
And I love to use this
next 19 minutes or so,
so that I can learn a little bit
about where we’re headed.
And a lot of the people
that are viewing this,
some of them are technical,
some of them are not.
So, I’m sure we --
Let’s try to find a balance of how
can we talk about this industry
at a bit higher level and
what opportunities are...
and what opportunities are
and what the constraints are.
Sure.
So, tell me a little bit about
Allegro really quick
just so we can have context
of what you’re interested in
and some of the things that
you’re researching.
Absolutely.
Actually, we do a little
bit of research, but --
I mean, this is also on team
communication and building...
- building models that's -- yeah.
- Sure.
Sure, sure, sure.
I mean, research always has
a specific foundation in AI.
- Yeah.
- But basically,
where we come at it or --
We’re about engineering
the research and I’ll explain.
So, the thing about AI --
and when I’m speaking about AI,
in my context,
it’s machine learning
and deep learning.
Basically, it’s a fundamentally
different paradigm
on how to do software.
Right? So, traditional software
is a very logical, linear
development process.
At its essence, it’s basically
engineers building algorithms
to solve problems,
and then coding them in a way
that a machine understands,
so then, a machine
can actually run it.
Whereas in machine learning --
deep learning,
what you’re actually doing is,
you’re employing algorithms
to come up with the algorithm
to solve the problem.
- Right.
- This is --
And so, you do this through
a process of iteration
and experimentation,
hence, machine learning.
Right? So, the algorithm
supposedly learns, right?
Yup.
And so, this is a very --
this is an experimentational
process rather than a standard
software process.
And this has fundamental
implications on everything else.
Right?
On the type of talent
that you need to basically
drive development
and maintenance of this,
on the type of tools that
you need, and how to integrate
workflows to make that work.
And so, what we do at Allegro
is we basically provide
an end-to-end tool chain
or platform,
whatever you want to call it,
that basically supports
the key pillars or aspects
of AI around the
paradigm so that our
customers can focus on
building and maintaining
their product or service,
so that they can focus on --
and therefore,
build a better solution,
faster, more cost-effectively.
Right?
At the end of the day,
we’re about engineering the
processes that are specific to AI
to make it more productive.
Okay. So, maybe give me
a brief context and a rundown
of what is the life cycle of an AI
project in terms of, let’s say,
that I now --
I want to take a team of
three other researchers
and engineers.
I want to solve my problem.
It’s that I want to know --
I want to know what my dog is
going to think next.
Okay? So I have a new puppy.
I know that he has patterns.
I just don’t know what they are,
of when he’s going to go
bite the couch.
And it's awful
because I’m going to
have to pay for this couch,
- because this is a rental.
- Right. Right.
So, how do --
what is the life cycle of such
a project from a machine-learning
researcher’s perspective?
Actually, you hit the nail
on the head, right?
That’s one thing to remember
for the non-technical
audience, right?
In a machine learning AI
and deep learning,
it’s not a solve-all solution
for everything.
- Right.
- It’s really about being able to
identify patterns in lots of data
or complex data and being able
to come up with predictions
as a result of that.
Right?
So, you hit the nail
right on the head on that.
And so, being able to understand
when your puppy
is going to bite the couch,
you’ll need to collect data.
Right?
To basically --
You’ll need to collect data
about the puppy’s behavior.
Right?
For a period of time during which
he may bite the couch or not,
and he’s just acting around.
Right?
So basically, in this case, you're
probably going to film him.
- Right?
- Yeah.
You could theoretically also put
some sensors around him and
measure other types of things
related to, maybe, his level
of anxiety or whatever,
- and blood pressure, right?
- Or I should follow him around,
so I can write logs of every single
thing he does.
Exactly, right?
And then so, basically, that’s the
first thing you need to do.
I mean, because data --
what we’d like to say is
it’s really the raw material
that drives the process.
- Right?
- Right.
And so then, what you’re going
to do is you’re going to have to
basically --
you’re going to have to
have a data scientist
or you’re going to have
to find someone
that is going to figure out,
"Okay, what is the best...
the best way to address this or to
build a solution to predict this?"
And what I mean by that is
you want someone to be able to
identify,
"What’s the right algorithms?"
There are a lot of algorithms
out there, right?
In deep learning,
they’re called neural networks.
In machine learning,
there’s a set of algorithms.
But which is the one that’s best
suited to solve this problem?
And there are obviously different
types of algorithms, each one
for different solutions,
optimize for them.
And then, you’re going to have
to basically build an experiment.
You’re building basically
an experiment where you’re saying,
“I’m going to take this data.
I’m going to assume this is
the right model for me.
I’m going to tune different
parameters around it.”
You have some --
think of it as a block
where you can actually tune
and change some levers.
And then, you’re going to run an
experiment and you’re going to
see the results.
And I just --
I want to also --
There is a differentiation because
I think there’s a misconception
that anybody who says,
"I’m a machine learning engineer,"
or something like that,
then people assume that
they’re a mathematical genius,
that they’re sitting and they're --
they’re creating the --
they’re necessarily creating these
new, unseen-before algorithms.
But a lot of engineers,
that are already working on
machine learning -- today, you have
all these democratized tools,
like Tensorflow and PyTorch,
and all these out-of-the-box
tools where you can --
even if you don’t know
machine learning at all,
you can say,
“Yeah, I have this data set.
I heard on the podcast that
this should be suitable
to a logistic regression.
So, let’s just try it out,”
and 'Oh, it works'
or 'it doesn’t work.'"
It’s true.
So, a lot of the big
plat-providers,
namely, mostly, you see Google,
Amazon, Microsoft, and some others
are providing tools that enable
people who have basic technical
affinity to be able
to do these things.
But the important
thing to remember,
at least, where I’m coming from in
the industry, is that these tools
are lowest common denominator.
They’re going to be able to maybe
solve a problem of a puppy.
But once you get into
situations where
the precision becomes
much more important
- because
- Right.
the cost associated within a stake
is going to be bigger,
say, autonomous vehicles, right?
- Yup. Yeah.
- Or something else, right?
Then, it’s not enough to have
a layman using these tools.
You’re going to have to actually
have people who are much...
much more knowledgeable, both on...
on different aspects
of this, right?
So, there are a lot of aspects.
There are the people
who are actually going to
to use their neural networks
and to do these stuffs,
and maybe even tweak them around,
and even --
We are working with companies
who even are smart enough
to actually be able to build
their own neural networks.
Yeah.
To them -- engineers who know
how to actually take that
and build a solution,
that's scalable solution, right?
And so, there are many --
you need to have a lot of
professionals in this
process, right?
- So, it depends --
- It really sounds like the --
It really sounds like the 80-20
rule, where you can get 80%
precision with 20% of the effort.
But if you want to get
a 100% accuracy,
and you want to make sure
that your autonomous vehicle
is going to be predictable
in these circumstances,
you’re going to have to put
100% of the effort
and go that extra mile.
Did you take a sneak peak
at some of our presentations?
- Because –
- Oh, no. I –
that’s exactly right.
You know who I grew up with.
And I’ve been hearing about this
from Berth, basically.
[laughs]
Yeah, it’s exactly that.
I heard somewhere,
and it's so true.
I mean building a prototype --
even building actually a prototype
of an autonomous vehicle
to drive in a parking lot
is very, very easy.
The problem is exactly that,
to build a real product.
That’s exactly the 80-20 rule.
Wonderful. Okay.
So, Allegro,
how is that helping
either democratize
machine learning and AI
so that others can use it,
or make it more efficient
and better for teams?
How does this whole process work?
Sure. So, we basically --
we help companies
in three or four pillars.
Right?
The first one is what we call
experiment management
or process management.
And this is really around
how do you manage
these different process
of experiments?
- Right.
- Right?
So, you have a lot of
experimentation that you’re doing,
and you need to basically be able
to pick and choose the best one,
compare them, go back and
maybe take a different direction
in your research, et cetera.
So, how do you actually
manage that process efficiently?
That’s one piece that we do.
The second piece --
and I’m going really fast,
high level here, right?
The second piece is around
this new space
called MLOps, right?
So, it’s the AI version
of DevOps, right?
And DevOps in a nutshell,
it’s about taking a single,
discreet piece of code
and scaling up over a lot
of computers
so that it can work
and scale, right?
To service a lot of users
or what have you.
Whereas, in AI,
you’re actually having lots
of different experiments
running at the same time.
And so, you need to have --
The problem is different.
You need to have
a way to scale up
lots of slightly different
pieces of code.
They’re about the same,
but they're slightly different.
And it’s a different problem.
The other thing is DevOps
usually happens in production.
And so, in standard software,
there’s a very clear delineation
between development
and production.
Right.
Whereas, in AI,
the need for a lot
of compute power
begins really, really early on.
- Yeah.
- As you --
know, right after you
built the initial modelling,
you now have to take more
compute power to do bigger,
bigger data sets.
And so, this is the area of MLOps.
And so, it’s a very different
problem than DevOps.
And we provide a really
simple solution for that
so that companies who have
data scientists can self-serve
themselves because that’s,
oftentimes, where the problem is.
They’re going to the DevOps
who don’t know exactly
what they need, and there’s
a lot of friction there.
So, that’s the second thing
that we help with.
- The third thing –
- You actually --
You actually own the GPUs and you
manage the running or are you --?
How does that actually
work over there?
Right.
We don’t own the GPUs
or any of the underneath hardware.
Our solution is 100% software.
Okay.
We basically provide an
orchestration
and a queuing layer to enable
data scientists to do this.
It can sit directly
on the hardware.
It can also sit on scalable
solutions like Kubernetes,
which were built for DevOps.
But a lot of companies
who have this want to
have their AI also on that.
So, we basically have this
kind of like translation layer
so that the data scientists
can build solutions easily.
And it then runs and it
kind of runs ultimately on
Kubernetes’ [UR] system.
Yup.
So, that’s the MLOps part of it.
The third pillar is around
data management.
And what I mean
by data management is really
metadata management.
It’s about the
insights of the data.
Like, when you’re looking at data,
think about your dog, right?
The video itself is meaningless
unless you basically say,
"Okay, here’s where your
puppy bit the couch,"
or "Here where he started
playing around," or whatever.
That metadata,
maybe, it’s nighttime
or daytime, or it's winter, right?
Those are the things that
actually potentially could affect
your puppy’s behavior, right?
And so, those are the things
that you need to manage.
And the thing is that you need
to understand data skews
and data biases,
because ultimately --
Let’s take an example
from autonomous vehicles.
Most of the time,
what you’re dealing with
is these really rare edge cases.
What happens when you’re driving
and the sun is exactly
shining through the camera,
and you’re making a left turn, and
someone’s coming from the right,
and there’s a stop sign,
whatever --
those edge cases are the ones
that you need to deal with.
And they’re rare.
And so, you don’t have
a lot of data on that.
And so then, what happens is,
actually, if you have too much data
of something else, and not
enough of these situations,
your neural etwork, your algorithm
is not going to learn well.
So, you have to rebalance
the data, et cetera.
So, building a solution
to do that, to really manage
metadata as raw material
for your process,
this is something completely new.
Companies like Google, Microsoft,
Amazon have internal
in-house solutions
built for that.
But 99% of the other
companies don’t.
- Right? And so --
- And they want to --
almost every start-up
either claims or actually does
AI work, yeah.
Yeah.
We can talk about that
at a different time.
I mean there are some amazing
startups out there but
you’re right,
a lot of unsubstantiated
claims are also out there.
So that's the third one.
It doubles your valuation
within a second.
So, of course you do.
And then, I guess the fourth
pillar is about collaboration.
And it’s really --
It’s about collaboration
and actually efficiency
of your human capital.
This has multiple facets.
So, the first facet is
your data scientists.
Really good ones, again,
we talked about the fact that
we’re solving problems
for companies who have
very high standards,
not your layman solutions.
And so, getting these very --
highly qualified research
scientists and data scientists,
super expensive
and very hard to find.
And so, if you have them, you want
to make sure that they’re as
productive as you can.
The second thing is
researchers and data scientists
have a very different mindset
than engineers.
Yup.
Because, again,
they’re doing research work.
But ultimately, you’re building
a product
which is an exercise
in engineering.
And so, there’s a friction there.
And the idea is how do
you actually make them
or how do you actually get them
to integrate well into a larger
product and engineering team?
So, obviously these have
a lot of aspects around
how do you manage it
organizationally, et cetera.
But it also has an aspect
around tooling, right?
For example,
how do you make sure
that you have  a tool
that enables a simple hand-off
between something that
the data scientist build
and engineer can actually
take and use
as containerized solution
that they don’t need
to understand what’s inside.
So, we facilitate those things
- Interesting.
- from that aspect
so that, on one hand,
data scientists can
become much more productive, but
also at the same time, be able to
hand off and integrate nicely
into the large organization.
So, those are the --
I guess four pillars of
how we help companies.
Wonderful.
And where is it at now?
So, Allegro, what’s happening
in realms of, you know,
in terms of the team
and funding, et cetera?
So, we’re a series A company.
We’re about 30 people.
We’re an open-source company.
So, most of our platform
is completely open.
And so, we’re actually undertaking
what Andreessen Horowitz calls
a B2B growth sales strategy.
So, we’re pushing
on getting a lot
of companies to adopt
our solution, knowing
that they’re going to
upsell into --
at some point to some
enterprise solution.
And so, that’s going well.
I can’t release numbers,
but we’re going really,
really fast.
That’s wonderful.
Okay. Nir, I have you
for just a few more minutes.
- Sure.
- But I'd love to --
And I'd love to pick your brain.
What are you most passionate about
in the realm of the AI space?
And if you think five years
down the line, realistically,
what are the things that you are
most excited about
that I will get to experience
in my 20s now?
[laughs]
What I’m most passionate about
is what got me here
in the first place.
I mean, this is --
So, I spent about
a decade at Google.
And after you are at Google and
you're doing a lot of things that
really impact huge swaths of
humanity, really, it’s --
you really learn about --
you want to innovate,
and you want to do something
that’s impactful.
And that’s really --
that’s been the driving force
for me across my whole career
―how to actually innovate and push
the envelope or be part of
something that pushes it
to the next stage,
and really be able to
have a large impact.
I think that AI, obviously,
is meant to have a large --
a huge impact on humanity
in so many aspects.
And so, for us, it’s really about
making that happen.
I think that there’s a really big
disparity between where the media
is today and what’s
actually happening.
Most of the companies
are struggling with this.
And so, to me, if you’re asking,
realistically, what we’re going to
see in the next several
years is we’re going to see
a lot of the --
the things that you’re already
seeing out of Google, et cetera,
becomes
standard, everyday things
where it’s normal
for you to do that, right?
It’s normal for you
to talk to a bot, right?
That’s completely animated.
It’s normal for companies
to be able to automatically
figure out who are the best
customers and where they
need to target it, right?
It’s very easy to be able to
understand what you’re seeing
in video, et cetera, right?
I had recently talked with
a product manager at Waymo.
And one of the very interesting
things that she mentioned was
the media and a lot
of companies were very quick
to make these crazy assumptions
that, yeah, by the year 2020,
we’re going to have
vehicles on the road.
But then, people --
because people though that
the problem was a little bit,
I think, easier than what it is.
And all of a sudden,
they got to 95% mark.
And then, they realized
that that last sliver,
which is critical when
you’re talking about lives,
that’s going to take
a little bit longer.
So, I agree.
And I definitely look
forward to seeing
more things progress.
I’m very excited about my own
studies with AI and getting
a deeper understanding myself
to be able to harness these
qualities as well.
We’re almost out of time,
but I have to ask you
my favorite question.
I would love to know
three words that you would best
describe yourself.
Very curious for that now.
Yeah. So, you warned me
about this,
- Yeah.
- right before but
I didn't have time
to think about it
But let me tell you about the --
So, let me give you
a different answer,
slightly different --
When I look at the leaders
and managers that I aspire
to be like, right?
I saw people who are pushing
the envelope,
who are able to take
bold decisions.
I saw people who deeply
care about the success --
their success within the context
of the organization,
not a me-first.
And also, deeply care about who --
their team and the people that
work for them, and their success,
again, within that context.
And then, at the end of the day,
having --
doing everything with integrity.
And so, when you ask me,
this is what I aspire to be.
I love it. I love it.
I think it's just --
And I’m sure it’s such a --
both fascinating, difficult,
and fun journey at the same time
to now lead a company that’s
growing quickly, and
you have to now really
formulate your own
leadership style,
and what does it mean
to be a leader in that aspect.
I recall you were captain
in the IDF as well,
which I’m sure has a...
a lot of connections to some
of the things that you’re
experiencing now.
But it sounds wonderful, Nir.
Best of luck with Allegro.
Thank you for the inspiration
over these last 20 minutes,
and I look forward
to keeping in touch.
Thank you so much, Michael.
It’s been a pleasure.
And obviously,
all the success to you.
And maybe, you can come work
for us or use our tools.
- Done. Bye-bye.
[laughter]
All right. Take care, Nir.
- Take care, Michael.
- Bye-bye.
Bye-bye.